what is going on everybody and welcome
to the eighth Monte Carlo in Python
tutorial video now that we've kind of
compared the two betters let's just
compare them visually within matplotlib
so we still have obviously a lot of
questions to answer here to take our
double or better for example should this
better actually reach say even ten times
his initial investment how wise would it
be that he continued one and because you
know we're certain on a long enough time
line this this doubler will lose
everything or could lose everything so
at what point you know would you be
content with your really like lottery
winnings you know so obviously we have a
lot of questions and what's nice about
the Monte Carlo simulator is that you
can answer a lot of these questions so
if you just google Monte Carlo simulator
and you look at like the Wikipedia
you'll see the typical example being
given of like the Monte Carlo simulator
being used to calculate pi the way it
does this is by purely testing variable
after variable to eventually root
forcibly solve the problem and it works
all right there's no need for math or
formulas besides obviously setting up
the program itself so with this problem
that we have where we have a lot of
questions we've got at least four or
five variables here that we need to
solve for and to do that I have no idea
how to even approach this mathematically
you know with this whole how big of a
wager how many wagers if we're gonna
multiple how many or multiply how much
of a multiple should we use and all that
but I do know that the Monte Carlo
generator can give us this answer so
anyway moving forward now what we want
to do is just kind of visually compare
these guys so the first thing that we'll
do eventually we will get rid of simple
better because he's boring but we do
want to like at least see how we can
visually compare these guys so the first
thing we're going to do is since we're
gonna be comparing them we want to use
the same variables like the starting
sighs how many wagers are we doing etc
and starting dollars so with that let's
go
and make some constants so we'll say
sample size and we'll just say 104 now
starting funds we'll say 10,000 since
we've been using 10,000 wager size
equals 100 and wager count equals we'll
do a thousand to start so that's all we
really need to do there and the other
thing that we'll do is we'll come down
here and where we plot so we can tell
the difference we'll add a third
parameter here and so double or better
is gonna be cyan and then coming down
here's our simple better and some better
same thing where he plots he's gonna be
instead of cyan he's gonna be K and if
you don't know K is black and matplotlib
so now we've got those things the next
thing we want to do is we can basically
leave all of this x equals zero and
instead of 10,000 will just say well X
is less than sample what do we do we
call this sample size I think camel
casing and then what we're gonna have is
we've got simple better and then we've
got the other better but first let's
fill these in so mmm starting funds the
next thing that we have is wager size
and then we'll do wager count it's that
simple better and then we'll do double
or better just copy that paste double or
better and that should be everything we
need we'll find out real quick if we did
something wrong anyways so let me just
go to the top and we don't really need
this stuff either we'll just leave this
out
sounds good and then just so I can edit
the variables we'll just scroll up so
we'll run this hopefully we don't get
errors sure enough we didn't so now you
can see kind of a comparison of these
two where this is obviously the block is
a simple better the cyan is our double
or better I mean you can visually just
see how how superior these options are
but again it's only more superior if
you're looking at it you know on the
long term scale so if you look at it
here you can see that depending on the
number of wagers that you're doing if
you're doing a very very small amount of
wagers it might make more sense to be
the simple better but as you can see
pretty quickly the double or better
starts pulling away and really all of
these guys are still in the game sort of
so as they continue going up you know
the simple better only has the
opportunity of getting you know so far
right so we can close this and let's
make a sample size of a thousand and
we'll do ten thousand wagers wait for
you you can already guess what's gonna
happen obviously the double or better is
gonna make a lot of money the simple
better is gonna do okay but he's gonna
drop long term and I can't remember at
what point we said there was absolutely
no life expectancy for the for this
simple better but I do we might actually
hit it so here we go
it looks like maybe a couple of them
survived let's zoom in and see if any of
our simple better survived yeah so this
guy actually survived and he made a
pretty good amount of money we've got
like these outliers right this one guy
here and this one got here and the rest
of them are like right in here but we
can see most of them actually did lose
money let's go back out again and I and
then we can see here that after a
certain amount of time we can see that
quite a few of our guys were successful
up here
very few of them failed again we're
still not really seeing a representative
sample of how many of these guys
actually went bust since we're not
allowing them to go bust at the moment
really or visually go bust but we will
edit that in in a little bit I just
wanted to show you guys a good
comparison at least the guys that ended
up you know here really did end up there
anyways so oh that's a comparison of the
two obviously I know which one looks
more appealing to me that's our double
or better and that just only makes sense
because on a long-term scale at least
some of our double or betters will still
be profiting whereas our simple betters
just must lose long-term so anyway
that's really all I wanted to do in this
in this video and in the next video but
I think we'll do is we'll fix the whole
going broke thing so for a double or
better we're only gonna allow him to
continue making wagers with what he can
afford so he can't go into debt same
thing with on 100 better it's not as bad
for him since he could only go a hundred
dollars in debt but he's still allowed
to continue on and our double or better
is allowed to make say a $200,000 wager
even if he only had twenty thousand
dollars so it's not a very
representative sample so let's go ahead
and fix that guy well both of these guys
in the next video
so anyways that's what you guys have to
look forward to as always thanks for
watching things for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time